i just had this new baby but i cried
non-stop for like three weeks kylie
jenner is getting real about her
postpartum journey kylie
baby number two
congratulations thank you kylie gave
birth while filming the kardashians for
hulu and season two promises to give
fans a glimpse into the mogul's life as
a newly minted mom of two i made a baby
this is my 11th grandchild
i need my first night out i haven't had
a night out in almost a year but a new
trailer for the show suggests it wasn't
all rainbows and butterflies for kylie
especially the weeks following the birth
of her son her second child with beau
travis scott born in february i should
be really happy right now i just had
this new baby but i cried non-stop for
like three weeks kylie's kept a candid
on social media in the lead-up to the
show's return sharing her struggles with
her fans i just want to say
to my postpartum moms that postpartum
has not been easy it's not been easy
it's very hard
it's this experience for me personally
has been a little harder than with my
daughter
it's not easy mentally
physically
spiritually
it's just
crazy and yeah i didn't want to just get
back to life without saying that we'll
have to wait to see how that plays out
on screen and hopefully we'll find out
what baby number two's name is on the
new season she and travis have yet to
reveal their mini-me's moniker after
originally announcing it to be wolf why
not wolf
and
what is the name wolf was never on our
list
it just was actually something
chloe suggested and i like don't do this
but i liked the name i don't think
anything i still like
i love it i love it i like wolf
i just wasn't him okay so it wasn't
against anything to do with the name it
just wasn't him yeah so here's to hoping
kylie and travis make the big reveal on
the show we have some um
we have some baby really strong options
but we haven't officially changed it on
top of kylie's second pregnancy the new
season also features chloe becoming a
momma of two
we got this we're built for this
our family grows first kylie now chloe
it's gonna be really exciting and i am
ready coco and her ex tristan thompson
who also share four-year-old daughter
true recently welcomed a baby boy via
surrogate it's a beautiful thing season
one focused on the not-so-happy lead-up
to chloe and tristan's baby news around
the time they got pregnant chloe learned
the nba star had cheated on her again
and this time the woman he cheated with
got pregnant did tristan have every
opportunity to tell me yes was tristan
going to tell me if there wasn't a baby
involved absolutely not and that shows a
lot about his character the entire thing
is despicable i think for every sister
we have different boundary levels and we
all try to respect that and
but i think
and probably moving forward we might all
have and like your boundaries are
allowed to change and mine will probably
change later but
i'm also i think a lot of us are you
know what is in the media is sort of
things that we feel we need to film
because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that we've shared so
much about our lives and fans should
expect nothing different in season two i
wish we could have one boring day in
this family
[Music]
you